trousse à bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec motion e rt france a tout d'abord
et quelle est votre réaction face à ces
manifestations contre les mesures de
restriction en italie les réactions ne
sont pas ce moment l'italie mais
commencent à paraître dans plusieurs
pays
en espagne aussi à barcelone c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les gens
commençaient comme à une exaspération
total on a joué beaucoup avec des gens
et des promesses avec une forme de lyre
et assurance par rapport à la manière de
traiter cette épidémie cette pandémie
alors on dit c'est tout nouveau
donc il faut absolument s'adapter mais
on nous allons nous a trompés parce que
le même chose
ils ont passé en france on d'haskanita
lui aussi avec les masques le test
ensuite le deck aucunement est
aujourd'hui la situation est même
compréhension pourquoi parce que on voit
des milliards qui sont je dirais
fabriquée avec de la planche à billets
sur de latif inexistant pour soutenir
une économie qui n'est pas une pas ce
que l'économie est en train de mourir à
petit feu dans le sens que le tissu
économique des échanges est en train de
disparaître au fur et à mesure et que
ces soins palliatifs par rapport aux
restaurateurs aux kaunas en petit aux
petites entreprises
c'est sont vraiment des soins palliatifs
quasiment comme si on donnait une sorte
de médicaments pour l'accompagnement
vers le tennessee et là il ya une chose
qui est incompréhensible parce que la
même chose se passe en france en italie
pourquoi depuis le mois de mars et
surtout depuis le mois de juin
conscients que nous sommes face à un
problème médical
on n'aime pas fait le nécessaire et
investi des milliards dans le secteur
hospitalier
et puis avoir pris conscience que le
problème ne principal de cette maladie
de cette épidémie
ce sont les personnes âgées les
personnes avec deco mobilité à l'italie
on les langues se délient et tout
commence beaucoup on commence les
communs le président tautil le président
de la région de ligurie le président de
la région de bbc
mais aussi des personnes âgées qui sont
conscients même que aujourd'hui on est
en train d'hypothéquer la vie de la
jeunesse des enfants dp des enfants des
adolescents des universitaires des gens
qui ont peu de liste même si certains
médecins pour poursuivre dans la tuerie
de la peur continue à dire que
effectivement la maladie touche une
surcouche tout le monde mais elle touche
surtout des personnes très âgées et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de tuer
80% de la population
nous sommes en train de tuer l'économie
pour protéger une partie de la
population que nous n'avons pas assez
protégé dire que il aurait fallu comme
cela avait été envisagé que depuis le
mois de mars les personnes âgées soient
traitées ni simple manière d'une manière
beaucoup plus digne alors que on a
choisi le confinement confinement pour
tout ce qui était super catastrophique
pour les personnes très âgées parce que
l'on connaît le marasme de des morts
dans les ehpad et aujourd'hui de le côté
les gens qui sont en bonne santé qui ont
eu le kobe qui arrive à sortir ne
comprends pas qu'il puisse pas continuer
d'autant plus que la question de kloster
dans les restaurants dans les petits
magasins avec commerces de proximité et
une question qui demeure ouverte tant en
italie qu'en france est aujourd'hui tout
justement est frappée par cette deuxième
vague vous avez l'impression que que les
gouvernements navigue à vue pour pour
gérer cette crise le gouvernement ou les
gouvernements que ce soit en italie ou
en france on essaie de préserver le plus
possible les gens on sait que cette
maladie est très dangereuse
l'économie va en souffrir et malgré ça
on voit quand même qu'il ya énormément
de gens dans la rue par exemple en
italie qui n'ont pas peur justement
d'être infectées aux convives 19
aujourd'hui
voilà la question est plus économique
c'est l'économie qu'il faut à faire
redémarrer
je pense que c'est pas du ciel
économique
il vient société ce n'est pas plus
l'économie la vie en société c'est la
ville ce sont la liberté la liberté
d'aller et venir ma liberté
d'entreprendre liberté d'échangé à
liberté dédié aujourd'hui nous avons un
virus qui affecte comme il ya
l'infection de la grippe tous les hivers
comme il ya d'autres affections ce virus
être
s'ils tiennent qu'ovide à partir de 1964
nous connaissons et aujourd'hui il ya
une sur réaction de la part de tout le
système
oui mais pas de médicaments il n'y a pas
de traitement en est le vaccin contre
cette maladie paie chère madame cela
fait 37 ans que nous vivons avec le sida
et on n'a pas trouvé un virus on l'avait
promis et c'est pas pour autant que les
gens auront arrêté de faire l'amour et
d'avoir des relations sexuelles
ça veut dire tout simplement que
aujourd'hui on nous vend l'hypothèse
d'un vaccin
mais il n'est même pas sûr que ce matin
il sera donc le problème de dire on va
tenir parce que le bac c'est arrivé à la
fin de l'année au printemps au mois de
juin on pourra pas vivre un set 2-1 ce
tiraillement social humain liberticide
pendant des mois les gens sont au bout
de souffle je travaille accor est leader
avec des psychologues
avec des psychiatres la situation
s'aggrave de plus en plus il ya une
certaine partie de la population qui
effrayé parce que on a quand même pour
utiliser la tuerie de la terreur la
terreur les messages sont constamment
porté sur la dangerosité être à fêter ça
ne veut pas dire allait inévitablement
en réanimation
ça ne veut pas dire mourir on a présenté
un spot ayant une scop et eric est celui
dans lequel on voit une fête avec une
année à suivre mais dans un lit reka
toyo c'est un scandale c'est un scandale
de communications médicales
c'est un scandale tout court et
aujourd'hui la problématique là où vous
avez habité par exemple cela fait des
mois et des mois
j'aurai l'occasion de me dire je vous ai
aujourd'hui je suis banni de certaines
chaînes parce que il faut surtout que
billet n'a pas série qu'il faut surtout
que on ne sort pas de cette vision cas
et que la maladie leur décontamination
et qu' il faut monter tout le monde le
masque partout alors que aujourd'hui
même la question de masques si
aujourd'hui les masques était la panacée
et c'était la solution pour quelles
raisons autant d'affection
depuis que l'espagne à l'italie à
l'italie à midi en france quasiment tout
le monde de porter un masque
là aussi il ya toutes les problématiques
mensongère le respect des gestes
barrières
là les gels hydroalcooliques le lavage
de mains ont été quasiment abandonnée
depuis qu'il est gens portent le masque
alors que l'on sait que 80 % des
infections se transmettent par le
toucher et pas par la voie des voies
respiratoires
donc il ya aussi malheureusement une
présentation de la maladie une
présentation de ce qui est cette
problématique amiral qui est faux c'est
bientôt 24 ans et 82 ans
cmaj moyenne des personnes qui décèdent
merci personnages n'ont qu'à noël baert
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne carlo
alberto brusa je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat et président de l'association en
réaction 19